Alright guys, so here is an example number two for the Holy Grail strategy. I'm looking at your AUD on the weekly timeframe. So for this example we're going to go from weekly to 4 over to 15 minutes. Okay? So right away you can see that we have taken out the weekly external liquidity which was this high over here. Now where is the fair value gap? This tiny little fair value gap is going to be a drawn liquidity which is just right here. There's no problem with gap here so that is going to be a draw. Let's go to the 4 over time frame now.
And let's see what has happened. So we took out the liquidity here right over here then we have a push-up and
Going into this level where you can see is that we have a shift in the market structure right here
Right so now we want to mark out the PD error in the discount. Sorry in their premium once we have this we want to look for the market for the
Premium family gap or auto vlogs. So right here. We also have a tiny
little variable you get right so price has now tapped into this level so
let's go here now once that happens we want to mark out this range low to
this range high this move right this was the last move to the downside before
before price starting moving up to the PD error so now going to the 15-minute
timeform what we need to do is to identify the consolidation phase right so
So over here we have this very clean consolidation and that is what you want to look for
in most cases.
Okay?
Right there.
We have a clean cut consolidation.
Then we have, you know, another consolidation phase here.
Then we have another consolidation or accumulation phase.
What do we want to call it?
Right?
And let me mark this out.
So now we are simply waiting for is a shift in the market structure and it happens
right away. So remember when I said that wicks matter for this strategy, right? We have a wick.
So that is giving a sign that okay, we have a break in structure now. So now,
where do we have the extreme friendly gap here? We have the friendly gap just around here,
right? So playing this through. Now what do we have? We have a shift in the market
section. Then we have a break of structure. So remember that second distribution entry,
we are looking for that at the moment. Okay? So let's see. So now we have a purge on this high over
here. We have also mitigated this fair value gap. Let me mark this out. This for value up here.
So now what you want to wait for is a double break of structure. And there we have our double
break of structure. We have a lower, lower, lower, high, lower, lower right there.
We didn't take this because we have lower low, lower high, lower low, but then there was
no further lagap, unmitigated further lagap here.
So now what we did, we considered this whole move as a lower low, lower high, lower low.
So now we have this further lagap and as you can see, we kind of maybe got in a entry
of this breaker block just here or we could have used the 50% of the further lagap because
it is way too big.
So using a 0.5 level, right?
This would have been your second distribution entry, right?
There, stop goes just around here.
And this is our drawn liquidity.
So let's see how this plays out.
All right, so as you can see, the take profit was hit.
So now the thing is, unlike my other basic strategies,
you have to look for these setups, right?
So you will not always get the tap on the extreme probability gap.
You have to look for those things that I've taught you in this whole update.
Okay, you have to look for second distribution entry.
If you get that setup, that is absolutely beautiful.
Okay.
And you can see that we have a break of structure right here.
Sorry, a change of, sorry.
We have a market structure shift here.
Then we have a break of structure, right?
And then we have a purge or A, B, C, D, right?
That's what I call it.
And then what you wait for is a double break of structure.
So now, if you really think about it here,
we also had a lower low, lower high and lower low here.
So you could have actually taken your entry from this
fair value gap here as well from the 50%
put your stop right above this high.
And you could have targeted this level.
No problem.
But in most cases, you can consider this
as a lower low, lower high, lower low as well.
Right?
There's no problem with that.
You have a small second distribution entry here as well,
but then you have a larger pullback
and that is absolutely fine.
Okay, if you have taken your entry from there,
that is also good because you are following the rules here,
right?
We literally had our entry here.
That is a valid entry.
We have a lower low, lower high, lower low.
And that is the entry from the 50%
or from this autologue right there.
So yeah, you could have taken your entry here as well,
because remember, our bias was set.
Our take profit was set with the defined consolidation.
So this should have worked.
Every single PD area is going to be respected.
So right here, this family gap was respected, right?
In the premium.
Right here, what do we have?
We have a break of structure.
This family gap was respected.
Then we have another break of structure.
What do we have?
Nothing here.
Actually, this can't right here.
We have another break of structure.
Price respects this autoblock.
And we keep going down.
Then we have the continuation perch or the A, B,
A, B, C actually here.
And then boom, to the take profit level.
So that's how you frame your trades.
If you can learn to do this guys,
it will require some practicing because normally you would be waiting for
press tap into your free value gap here right but then as I told you the
second distribution entry you have to keep that in mind we mediate only this
free value gap and then the setup provided us the the second distribution entry
we could have got it in here or consider this whole move as a lower low lower
high a lower low and entry of the 50% level our bias was strong so we targeted
this level. So let's move on to the next example now.